hey guys merry here the game spot news
update Xbox one owners can now pre-order
the season pass for fallout 4 430
dollars you can pre-order the season
pass for fallout 4 or you can buy the
deluxe edition for $90 on the xbox one
marketplace which includes the game as
well as the season pass unfortunately
it's not yet available on PSN or pc but
Bethesda's marketing executive Pete
Hines shares fans to stay tuned for more
info on those platforms although details
on the DLC are still scarce Bethesda has
confirmed that it will include multiple
expansions the first will release in
early 2016 back in September Bethesda
said since we're still hard at work on
the game we don't know what the actual
DLC will be yet but it will start coming
early next year based on what we did for
oblivion fallout 3 and Skyrim we know
will be worth at least forty dollars and
if you do more you'll get it all with
the season pass in addition but that
just says it's planning regular free
updates to fallout 4 as was the case for
Skyrim then these will introduce fixes
and new features alike fallout 4 hits
xbox one playstation 4 and pc on
november tenth of this year for
everything else on that post apocalyptic
RPG be sure to stay tuned the game spot
you